so we all know that theaters have
struggled this year but now
variety reports that in just five days
the new release of godzilla versus kong
made almost 50 million dollars at the
box office
yep and these days that is a feat it's
the only movie to do
anything close to that it sold all those
tickets even though
people had the option of watching it at
home on hbo max simultaneously
and the big event movie apparently is
not dead in the summer we've got so many
big ones coming up check this out this
slate is hot
cruella can't wait for that i mean emma
stone is just everything so i'm already
there
also space jam 2 which i know you're so
excited about my kids love space jam
we love 101 dalmatians so like these two
we are definitely hitting
and then i am also so excited about in
the height
this is the one i cannot wait for if you
haven't seen the trailer you guys google
it
it is like it'll give you chills yes it
gives me chills and so
you know i mean i think this is a good
sign i think movie theaters want to come
back in 2022 but i think the game is
forever slightly changed it's completely
changed because just like this this
kong movie right people went to the
movie theaters where they're open to
view
but it was available and i think movies
are going to have to do that
stream at home if you want to but go
back to the movies and i will tell you
this
i was thinking maybe i'll need i don't
need to go to the theater again
but just the idea you guys thinking
about smelling that popcorn and paying
20
for red vines i'm kind of missing that
that whole experience
i don't miss the prices of the
concessions well that's i think that
needs to take a deep look into itself
seriously like with this economy i
should not charge these prices yeah
i will admit it has turned me into a
criminal because i have
popped my own popcorn and snuck it in a
duffel and i know
i know i'm a bad boy i mean i've taken
my kids and
checked out and it's like 65 at the
concession stand and i'm just like
for some cokes and some popcorns and for
some red vines and i just think
it's too much it's too much can i ask
though what is your go-to at the movie
theater what do you get
and concessions um well i i used to love
whipping my friends with red vines i
um that was a fun prank i used to play
on my friends as a kid
i love the concession stand i just want
families to not feel priced gouged when
they go
totally agreed hey we got even more
hopeful news in today's
green news
okay now i have never been to venice
italy have you been
yeah um i want to go so bad uh everyone
that goes there falls in love and now
cnn reports
the historic city has finally banned
cruise ships which apparently was like a
big deal
cruise ships have a big footprint you
know and activists have fought for this
for a decade
to protect venice from further erosion
and floods an alternative terminal it'll
be built outside the city
and for next steps climate activists
hope it'll include
plug-in power technology so when a
cruise ship
docks they can totally cut their
emissions
which is great news for a historic city
i can't wait to visit
um one thing i want to admit right now
is that i love cruises
i yeah i know i know i'm that i'm i'm
all about it
okay i go on i love them packing once
and every time you open up your window
if you can afford a window
you are in a brand new space i love a
floating buffet
but i do feel guilty about the footprint
so i love that they're doing this
when the pandemic started you know the
air in beijing had cleared out and the
dolphins were back in the canals of
venice we could
see the improvement when we backed off a
little bit
so i'm so grateful to the cruise ship
industry
and everybody who fought for this this
to me
is the kind of hope that we really need
we need to see
this action and then that inspires us as
individuals to do our part because i
know
for the last 20 years i thought what
what is my part going to do
yeah it's all it's all the things
yeah the industries and the individuals
and i think this is a way of how
we'll never go back to normal but the
new normal
can be so we can just be armed with such
knowledge of what we know now
right yeah so check this out the ncaa
women's championship wrapped this
weekend with stanford taking the title
and at the championship game people
magazine reports that the university of
arizona coach
adia barnes was able to fit in a quick
pumping session during halftime
no i don't mean working out she has a
six-month-old daughter
who was hungry at the game and a
sideline reporter named holly rowe
shared this behind the scenes detail and
said quote
for those of you who think this is too
much information let's normalize working
mothers and
all that they have to do absolutely this
story
really spoke to me rossi well yeah i
mean it's just it just proves like how
incredible
women mothers are they can multitask
like crazy i can do like half a thing at
a time and here she is like a real quick
timeout i'm going to go
feed my child mid-game it's amazing i
mean
i just have to say my deepest deepest
respect
and i'm just amazed at women and
uh we all know how we got here so thank
you uh for all that you do
yeah i just hope the basketball coach
didn't spill because that would be a
double dribble
you